people transition from remote working
back to the office animal shelters are
seeing a surge of surrendered pets
the nevada spca are concerned about the
hiking cases
and that it will only rise over the
coming weeks and months
christian casara is joining us live in
studio with ways to avoid making this
tough decision and how to go about it
without injuring the pet
well brian the pandemic has forced many
people to make tough choices one of them
is giving up their pets people are
moving and sometimes pets
are not allowed in the new homes or
money is just tight the nevada scpa has
a pet pantry food program completely
free
for dogs and cats by appointment only
they want to help struggling families
keep their fur babies and
avoid any type of separation now if you
decide to surrender your pet they ask
that you
first make an appointment this way you
can update the staff with health and
needs of the animal
for future care they ask that you do not
leave the animal
outside their door because the heat can
obviously be very
dangerous surround surrendering surround
i'm sorry surrendering a pet is a very
hard decision according
to the organization that is happening
more often every day
we've had some very tearful goodbyes
from pet owners
that we treat respectfully and privately
it's a hard transition the nevada scpa
tells us that another spike in cases
could be coming
as the residential eviction moratorium
is about to expire but moving away they
say
is the main reason families surrender
their pets
now on the flip side there are plenty of
animals looking for their forever home
just another reminder that there are
always options and resources available
christian gossett has 8 news now the